hospital admissions from covert 19 are
at record levels in some states in
australia the country's in the grip of a
third wave of the omicron variant with
more than 300 000 cases recorded this
week and a peak expected in august i
think there's still a little bit of
uncertainty but
we're probably going to reach record
numbers and record numbers in hospital
potentially in various parts of the
country now which is the concerning bid
and as i said we're starting from a
complete position of disadvantage in
having hospitals which are completely
full as they normally are
australia is among the most heavily
vaccinated countries against covert 19
95 of the population above the age of 16
has received two doses the federal
government is now offering a fourth dose
to those over 30 years but so far
there's been caution to take up the
offer the fourth shot gives additional
protection we've seen that very clearly
from across the world
so essentially we just need to get more
of those shots in the new wave of
infections is not just being felt here
in australia but also across the asia
pacific even micronesia which had been
covered free until now has had its first
case reported in the community
epidemiologists are encouraging pacific
nations to expand the rollout of the
fourth dose of the covert 19 vaccine to
avert a spike in infections
in countries particularly in the asia
pacific region where a lot of countries
kept their infection rates down didn't
have a big history of infections but
we're relying on our vaccination we
still had the same problem that we we
ended up needing the booster to really
get that protection from these new
sub-variants
the new sub-variants are the latest
challenge to china's zero-covered policy
with shanghai rolling out mass testing
and residents now required to take a pcr
covert 19 test at least once a week
until august
in the chinese territory of macau a
government-imposed extended lockdown
will be lifted and casinos allowed to
reopen on saturday
in south korea new cases are nearly 10
times higher than a month ago with
nearly 70 000 cases on friday and a
warning from the health agency that it
could surge to over 200 000 daily cases
next month
sarah clark al jazeera